[Music]
did you ever make anything happen and I
think you couldn't explain you're a
wizard Harry I'm a lot
dear mr. Potter we are pleased to inform
you that you have been accepted a
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry in a few moments you will pass
through these doors and join your
classmates keep an eye on the staircases
they like to change
[Music]
good afternoon cars welcome to your
first flying lesson take your right hand
over the broom and say up
[Music]
[Music]
my kid mr. Potter
our new celebrity first-years should
note that the dark forest is strictly
forbidden
with no magics to be used between the
classes of the corridors
the third-floor corridor is out of
bounds to everyone who does not wish to
suffer a most painful death understand
this sorry because it's very important
not all Wizards are good on gates bed
before either of you come up with
another clever idea to get us killed or
worse expelled see nice saw her
priorities
I think it is clear that we can expect
great things from you
[Music]